hello i'm daniel craig and i have some
questions here um
which i'm gonna try and answer
okay here we go what convinced you to be
part of no time to die
um
i felt like doing no time to die was
a chance to wrap up all the loose ends
and to finish off what i'd started
15 years ago
and i think we've done that and and more
what was your experience like shooting
in my home country of morocco morocco is
one of my most favorite places to go to
in the world
that year i went walking in the atlas
mountains so i got to see a lot of
morocco that year and i i love being
there and we'll get back there as soon
as i can how do you think your betrayal
of james bond has evolved with today's
perception of masculinity
um
i hope he's changed a lot while i've
been part of him because what i've
always tried to do is never judge him
he's he's um he's flawed and his
attitude towards the world and towards
women is questionable and i think that's
interesting the way i we've tried to
deal with it
um is to cast as stronger female
characters as possible have him go up
against those people and we had judy for
a long while i was very lucky and
privileged to work with her and that
that relationship informed who he is but
also exposes him for what he is and i
think that's interesting i don't judge
the characters i play i can try and i
try and let the audience do that hey
daniel why the choice to go with fewer
gadgets with your james bond
this is going to be i'm going to answer
this is going to answer a few questions
actually i've
loved the gadgets
but my
take on them has always been they've got
to sort of just to be justified in the
movie you can't really just have gadgets
for gadget's sake they've got to make
sense and they've got to be
interesting my favorite gadgets from the
previous movie is always i think my
favorite gadget is i think sean conner
used to use this sort of like little
silver box with a switch on it and the
red light went on i don't know what it
did but it kind of opened doors it kind
of blew things up and it was just that
was you know simple simple as best as
far as gadgets is concerned
daniel have you been injured a lot while
filming these movies which is the worst
injury in here
um
i have but that's just par for the
course it's a physical role and i get
bashed up and um in fact all that i mean
you know i'm i'm i get injured but the
stunt team get injured all the time and
thankfully we all walk away and that's
that's that's all that matters um i i i
broke my ankle on the uh the last movie
i broke my leg on the previous movie
and i'm still here
why have there been longer intervals in
between james bond movies during daniel
craig's era because i broke my leg
curious to know what stunt from your
times bond you are most proud of and
what's your favorite stunt from the
series my favorite stunt i've done
there's a few on no time to die i'm very
proud of
but
probably the whole sequence that we
filmed in venice on casino royale and
not least of all because that wasn't a
lot of stunt work but chris corbett who
designs our
physical effects so that's the things
that everything that blows up and
everything that you know like and he
designed the sinking venice house which
was a venice house that sank into water
and then reset and kept going so we had
to be filming in that and i had to be
jumping off things and flying into water
so i'm i'm most proud of that probably
because it's my first movie and it just
was
just one of the most incredible sets
i've ever been on
uh what has been your favorite outfit as
your time as bond and which fit from the
past is your all-time favorite
um
connor knew how to wear a suit um i
don't remember which director it was but
the director told connery to wear the
suit home and sleep in it
and then come and wear it and i think
that is how you should wear a suit i'd
say all of the tom ford suits i've worn
we work really hard with them
to create the look uh they've been
so cooperative over the years in my
during my tenure and they've uh allowed
us to mess around with their suits and
together we i think
produced some amazing
amazing suits
trunks
yep
are you as obsessed with them as your
fans are no
which was your favorite car to shoot in
the db5 it's like the
most one of the most beautiful cars ever
made i mean i've driven the dbs and the
brand cars and they you know they don't
break down quite as often but the dv5 is
definitely the car
what will you most fondly remember about
your time as bond and do you have any
regrets no i don't have any regrets
what i remember most formally about
doing bond are the people i get to work
with
um hello from sweden what has been your
favorite international location to shoot
in and why we filmed in chile in the
atacama desert
which is one of the highest driest
points in the world
and this has the clearest sky at night
because there's an observatory there
where you have stars from
horizon to horizon i think that was
remains one of the most amazing places
i've ever filmed it
what was the most challenging fun scene
to shoot
jesus five movies what the [ __ ]
um
the crane sequence in casino was one of
the most challenging and fun scenes
because when i started casino royale i
was afraid of heights
and
and after it i wasn't so i had to go up
about 60 feet onto scaffolding
and walk a walk along um
beams that were about six inches across
no run across beams that were six inches
across 60 feet up in the in in in the
air
which was uh wasn't fun but was
challenging what would you like your
portrayal of james bond to be remembered
for
uh the gags
how has james bond changed daniel craig
james bond has changed my life
immeasurably i mean it's like and
and 99 of it for the better um and i
would say it's
it's been
i could never imagined
of being where i am today without james
bond so
it's been
an extraordinary part of my life
uh which one is your favorite james bond
movie and why
goldfinger i think is my favorite james
bond movie um i love dr no but it was
sort of where sean connery became
the james bond that we know and we love
who is your favorite actor
to have played
um james bond clearly me
sean connery which one informed your
performance the most
none of them i mean i know that sounds
weird but actually
what i did when i when i took on the
role was i said i can't do impressions
of people i can't try and be sean
connery or pierce or roger i have to try
and be myself so
as much as i watch the films over and
over again and they influence the way we
shoot the movies
i just tried to be me
uh how are you daniel can you do a sean
wow i'm very well thank you can you do a
sean connery impression for us noop uh
what makes daniel craig's james bond
different from his predecessors i play
him what can you tell us about the
villain in no time to die and what did
ramy manic bring to the role
his grammy is we were incredibly lucky
to get romney he just off the back of an
oscar he's one of the most popular
actors in the world
at the moment and
he came and
hid out the park he's extraordinary in
this role um because he's an
extraordinary actor how has it been
working with phoebe wallabridge what did
she bring to the script she's one of the
most talented writers around and we were
incredibly lucky to have her
is there anything else
no jesus